family and neighbors coming out tonight
to remember a two-year-old hit and
killed at a park last night
they gathered at that park near lamb and
owens for a vigil
while remembering the boy people also
spoke about another issue they say they
fear will take another life
madison kimbrough joins us in studio
tonight with more
family and friends gathered tonight for
miguel angel morales
the two-year-old boy was hit and killed
last night while crossing the road
at a nearby park and police say the
driver was not speeding
but people who live in the neighborhood
are using the tragedy to shine light
on another issue they're dealing with
i've seen that little boy
a lot of times he'll be like a little
scooter
or something like that but he was never
alone it's just overwhelming that it
just happened so fast
two-year-old miguel angel morales was
killed monday night
after being hit by an suv while crossing
the road near douglas a shelby park
according to police the driver was
attempting to exit the park when the
child ran into the path
of her vehicle while speeding wasn't
determined to be a factor neighbors say
racing in the neighborhood is a big
problem
and they don't want to see another child
lose a life especially at night
like when the sun starts going down you
just start
hearing and seeing you know guys or
girls or whatever doing donuts here and
it's very dangerous because there's
always just like little kids in the
streets they speak through here like
it's a freeway
and you'll be looking like who in the
world will be doing that when there's
kids could be out here playing kids
could be running kids could be doing
anything a visual was held for miguel
where people laid out flowers
candles balloons and stuffed animals in
his honor
his mother maria morales who doesn't
speak english said she just wants
justice for her child neighbor and
family friend joanna aragon
rushed to the scene once she heard the
news she says she still can't get the
image
out of her head me and my husband run
over there and we just see the baby
on the floor he was he was really bad i
couldn't go to work
today i can't even sleep just it was a
trauma
and when officers arrived on scene they
found the little boy unresponsive
he was transported to the hospital where
he later died details about the woman
who hit him have yet to be released but
according to neighbors
the 19 year old lives in the
neighborhood now two gofundme pages have
been set up and we have both of those
links
up on our website reporting live in
studio madison kimbrough 8 news now